مساء الخير الاهتمام والتركيز الشريد جدا
على اسباب صعود ترامب المفاجئ للبيت
الابيض نسى ناس كتير جدا انه ترامب ليس
حاله معزوله وان صعوده للبيت الابيض وان
كان مفاجاه بسبب شخصيته الغريبه لكنه ليس
غريبا صعود
اليمين الشعبوي او اليمين المتطرف الذي
ينتمي اليه د ترامب احنا شرحنا في حلقه
منفصله اليمين واليسار النهارده بنحاول
نتناول جزء ثاني من هذه الظاهره او يعني
جانب اخر يتعلق
باسباب صعود اليمين في كثير من الدول
المتقدمه اذا كانت الولايات المتحده ممثله
في دخول دونالد ترامب وكثير من انصاره الى
السلطه
وارتفاع حظوظ
اليمين باطياب المختلفه في كثير من دول
العالم شايفين زي فرص فرانسوا فيو مثلا في
فرنسا المرشح الاكثر حظا حتى هذه اللحظه
في الانتخابات الفرنسيه وشفنا انه اليمين
بافكاره المختلفه ما صعد للسلطه في
بريطانيا لكن كان احد اسباب خروج بريطانيا
من الاتحاد الاوروبي عندنا في بلد زي
المجر رئيس وزراء فعلي بينتمي الى اليمين
المتشدد اللي هو فيكتور اوربان وعندنا
امثله اخرى في في في فلندا وعندنا في
هولندا وعندنا في ايطاليا
ف اليمين حتى وان لم يصل الى السلطه
بالضروره في كثير من هذه الدول فهو فهو
اصبح في وضع افضل وفرصه في استطلاعات
الراي بتقول انه في وضع افضل من اي وقت
مضى منذ سنوات هنا الاسباب ايه اللي بتادي
الى صعود امثال ترامب في هذه الدول كل
التحليلات اللي بترصد بتتكلم عن اسباب هذه
الظاهره بتتكلم على ايه على سبب اقتصادي
بالدرجه الاولى وبتقول انه اصحاب الدول
الغنيه
[موسيقى]
او المواطنين المواطنين في الدول الغنيه
يشعرون بالغضب والاحباط
نتيجه تراجع اوضاعهم الاقتصاديه نتيجه
العولمه اللي معناها ايه انه المستثمرين
والاثرياء في هذه الدول فضلوا ان ينتقلوا
باستثمارات الى دول اقل تكلفه زي الصين
وزي الهند وزي دول اخرى في اوروبا الشرقيه
او حتى في عالمنا العربي بس احنا بينق لنا
الصناعات الملوثه للبيئه زي الاسمنت مثلا
والاسمده فده بيسب فرص عمل لكن كمان هم
اكثر انزعاجا من وجود موجات كبيره من
الهجره اللي بتمثل اللي بتنفسه على فرص
العمل اما لانهم اكثر كفاءه او لانهم ارخص
في الاجر ده اثر عليهم بشكل كبير ده سبب
مهم جدا من الاسباب اللي ادت الى نجاح
ترامب وغيره والستات سكس او الاحصاءات
بتوضح انه هيلاري كلينتون خسرت في كل
البلاد اللي ارتفعت فيها نسبه البطاله في
السنوات الاخيره لحكم
اوباما كمان ليس سرا واصبح انه معروف جدا
انه اكثر الناس تصويتا لاباما ل دونالد
ترامب كانت الطبقه المتوسطه من البيض
اللي هم متوسط التعليم او قليل التعليم
ودول يسهل منافستهم من المهاجرين ومن غير
المهاجرين اقصد من المهاجرين اللي بيجوا
بلدهم او
من الناس الصينيين والهنود اللي بينفسن
قاعدين في بلادهم باستقطاب استثمارات
الامريكيه الى بلدانهم طيب ده سبب لكن
كمان في سبب تاني ان في قاسم مشترك بين كل
هذه الاحزاب اليمنيه في خطابها
وهي دقها الشديد جدا من الهجره نتيجه
المهاجرين مش بس الاسباب اقتصاديه ولكن
نتيجه تعصب يعني خليط من التعصب الديني
والعرقي تجاه كل من هو مختلف وبيتم ولذلك
هم بيكرهوا المهاجرين او بيعاد المهاجرين
بكل اشكالهم لكن تحديدا
الاسلاميين هل احنا هل هل المسلمين لعبوا
دور في صعود هذا التيار المتعصب الحقيقه
بدون ادنى شك نعم ومنذ سنوات طويله
ونقدر مش من المجهد او مش من الغريب جدا
ان نجد انه هذا التيار صعد بعد صعود
طيارات يمينيه دينيه متشدده في عالم
العربي ما احنا بنسمي داعش والنصره وغيرهم
من الطيارات السلفيه بكل اشكالها بكل
اشكالها ده بيعتبر يمين يمين ديني متشدد
يعني ده برضو من من اشكال اليمين الاحزاب
اليمينيه او القوى
اليمينيه اشتعال او صعود قوى زي داعش
والنصره
وكل يعني كل هذه القوى الاسلاميه في
العالم العربي والعالم الاسلامي
وتهديدهم للغرب
بكل بانهم سوف يهاجمونهم بكل ما اوتوا من
اسلحه و العمليات اللي بتتم من خلال ما
يسمى بالخلايا النائمه لداعش وغير داعش في
كثير من دول العالم صور هؤلاء وهم بيتباهو
بذبح الرهائن من بينهم رهائن غربيين كل
الكلام ده فضلا عن الخطاب المتشدد
والصدمات اللي بيتل قها بعض مواطني العالم
الغربي اللي هنا طبعا مش هم مش يعني مش
بصورهم على ان هم كائنات بريئه لكن انا
بقول لكم وجهه نظرهم هم ايه
يعني ايه الصدمات اللي بياخدوها في مستشرق
هولندي اسمه هانس يانسن وهو بيعتبروه في
هولندا حجه في قضايا الاسلام والمسلمين
والعرب وانا تحدثت ليه اكثر من مره هو قال
لي كده بالنص المسلمين خطر على اوروبا
ووجودهم عليه علامات استفهام وبيعتبر
وجودهم غير مرحب بيهم لما بساله ليه بيقول
لي انت تخيل نفسك مواطن هولندي وبعدين
بياتيك مهاجر مسلم
هذا المهاجر يحصل على دعم من الدوله ويحصل
على تعليم ويحصل على حمايه ويحصل على كافه
اشكال الرعايه الاجتماعيه في بلد زي
هولندا ثم زي ما بعضهم طلع هو بيديني مثل
بعض هؤلاء المسلمين خصوصا منهم المتدين
يعتبرنا ان
احنا اشر من الدواب وان احنا كفره وانه
يجب ان احنا
نستبعده هذه الافكار بتكون صادمه جدا
للغرب الافكار دي سواء كانت وجهه نظر هانس
يانسن سليمه او غير سليمه وجهه نظرهم ان
في قوى متشدده بتحاول تخترق مجتمعاتهم
وتغير ثقافتهم النتيجه مع تصاعد اليمين
الديني الاسلامي تصاعد كمان
اليمين المتطرف المسيحي في العالم الغربي
في
عالم في علم الاجتماع مهم جدا اسمه روجر
بيترسن ده عمل كتاب منذ عده سنوات لكن
مازال الاهتمام به قائم سماه اندرستاند
او محاوله لفهم التطرف العرقي بيقول
معلومه لطيفه جدا انه عاده بيتم في عنف
طائفي لما بيكون في اي فئه في المجتمع
كانت بتتمتع بالحضور والامتيازات
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه ثم لاي سبب من
الاسباب يتسرب هذه الامتيازات الى طائفه
اخرى او الى جنس اخر بتشعر باللي سماه
ريزنت مننت او الغضب النتيجه انها بتلج
الى العنف تجاه الطوائف والمذاهب
الاخرى طب علاقه ده ايه باللي انا بقوله
على اليمين والولايات المتحده
وصعود
اليمين من وجهه نظر بيترسن انه اللي حصل
في الولايات المتحده هو عباره عن ان كان
في فئه تشعر
بالحظوظ
يعني الامتيازات وهي الطبقه البيضاء
المتوسطه اللي هي اصل امريكا زي ما
بيقولوا النتيجه ان هذه الطبقه فقدت كثير
من مزاياها لان وظائفهم تسربت اما الى
المهاجرين من جنسيات مختلفه اللي اتوا الى
الولايات المتحده او لان وظفهم خرجت
الى يعني مواطنين من الوان اخرى في دول
اخرى لانهم ارخص ارخص كايدي عام الطبقه
الغاضبه ديت حبت تعبر عن غضبها لما بتكون
في بلد قوي زي الولايات المتحده ما تقدرش
ترجا الى العنف في الشوارع ولكنها تلجا
الى محاوله لتغيير الوضع القائم بكل السبل
المشروعه وكان منها انتخاب رجل زي دونالد
ترامب في مقابل الحزب الديمقراطي او
هيلاري كلنتن نفس الكلام ده شبيه جدا بما
يحدث في العراق او بما حدث في العراق احنا
كان عندنا السنه يحكمون العراق منذ
الخلافه
العباسيه بغض النظر عن وجود اغلبيه من
الشيعه احنا عندنا دوله في النهايه مكونات
دوله ماهش دوله حديثه فيها اعتبارات
عنصريه وفيها اسف اعتبارات طائفيه
واعتبارات مذهبيه فضلا ان الاعتبارات
الموجوده دي غزاها غزتها الولايات المتحده
عند غزوها للعراق النتيجه لما حدث لاول
مره تغيير في التركيبه السياسيه في العراق
منذ الخلافه العباسيه والى الان وخرج
السنه من الحكم حتى تتولاها الحكومات من
المذهب الشيعي كانت النتيجه انه انطبق
عليها ما قاله روجر بيترسن ان حصل في حاله
غضب ورفض وبدا قطاع من السنه يمارسون
العنف تجاه الطائفه الاخرى الشيعيه وبدا
الشيعه يبادلونه عنفا بعنف فده يفسر لنا
ان في وجه تشابه الفرق بس ان العراق بلد
منفلت في اعقاب غزو دمره ففرص اللجوء الى
العنف بالسلاح قائم امريكا بلد قوي ففرص
اللجوء الى السلاح محدوده جدا لكن اللجوء
الى التغيير بالوسائل الاخرى قائم ومتاح
وعشان كده ظهر في امريكا دونالد ترامب
وعشان كده ظهر في العراق ابو بكر البغدادي
حالتين سببهم متشابه والفارق فقط في ال
الظروف وا يعني امكانيات كل بلد من
البلدين اشكر والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله